[Music]
now if you were lucky enough to get into
the Ghost Recon wildlands beta you might
be wondering what now well we've got you
covered here are five tips to get the
most out of your Bolivian escapade and
if you didn't get into the beta make
sure to subscribe and we'll keep you up
to date on everything goes to recon
number one get to know the skill tree
even though Ghost Recon wildlands isn't
technically an RPG you'll still be
leveling up and building your character
over time every time you level up you
are in skill point and in order to
unlock new skills there are three things
you need to keep in mind the level
requirement skill points and resources
such as fuels medical supplies and
electronics different perks and unlocks
require different resources in a varying
amount of skill point number two find
your wings now that we got that out of
the way the next thing you should do is
get the parachute you're going to be
spending a lot of time in planes and
helicopters if one goes down the last
thing you'll want is to become an actual
ghost in order to get the parachute
first go to your skills menu the unlock
cost one skill point and 550 electronic
resources number three loot everything
if you've messed around with your
loadout at all you probably noticed your
arsenal is kind of lean to start off
with let's fix that shall we
I've been wanting one of these scattered
around the map you can find crates with
weapons in them such as this super
shoddy
or smaller ones like this contain weapon
attachment the fastest way to find them
is with Intel the right Intel can
receive several attachment location
number for grenade launcher beats
helicopter helicopters are obnoxious
once one of these birds has you in its
sights it won't leave you alone the
quickest way to swat these pesky things
out of the sky is by unlocking the
grenade launcher give it a bit of a lead
and she's gone
to unlock it you're going to need to
head back to your skills menu if you're
level 5 it will cost you two skill
points and 450 electronic resources
number five plays smart if you decide to
play with friends which you totally
should make sure to mic up and diversify
your loadout it's usually a good idea
for everyone to have at least one mid to
long range weapon so everyone can
participate in sync shop however when
you're in the field it's smart to have
someone to cover you from a distance
while the rest of your team moves into
complete objective if you decide to play
by yourself you will need to unlock
additional sync shots for the rest of
your squad and there you have it 5 tips
to get you started in the Ghost Recon
wildlands beta if you enjoyed this video
and you want to know more about Ghost
Recon wildlands we did a segment on our
weekly live show called the lobby be
sure to check that one out and in the
meantime I'll see you on the battlefield
[Music]